hello everybody welcome to let's play
amnesia Justine alright I'm a big dumb
idiot because I was searching around the
internet for where to download this
expansion for the longest time and it
was right there in the launcher I just
didn't see in the bottom right corner
there's a little button that says
Justine so I'm an idiot basically is
what I'm trying to say anyway there was
something in the beginning of this that
said death is final
so I'm guessing if I die things aren't
gonna go so well for me okay alright
okay everything's good let's go oh that
looks good alright hopefully I've got
all the webcam controls like right on
the money now because I've been tweaking
with it up trying to get just my face
properly exposed with all the background
dark and I think I got it if not I'm
just talking out loud uh right off the
bat hi are you
Oh get out of here get out of here man
get out of here it's too early to be
bugging me
see something up there I think is a look
looks like a lantern good night
gimme gimme good give me give me Papa
come on come on gimme gimme yeah locked
firmly oh here we go come on okay oh boy
no kidding
almost find you still gonna find you I
did you welcome to my cabinet of
preservation
it is my study of the human psyche hmm
my recordings have been prepared to
chaperone near through the chambers
ahead why thank you
there are a few parts to the study and
it is up to you not only to pass but to
figure out what elements are important
hmm
need go on move into the next chamber
okay
they can all be safe oh who who can be
saved
Oh Oh Hey haha yeah gimme gimme
oh yeah who the man I don't know what I
did but I did it I win
okay can't run why can't I run run
uh creepy good that was at the mosque oh
okay
sound seems to be clearing up
I think what's down there hey how's it
going guys that's some bright light I
want to go down there creepy up here
okay where am I I'm like lost
oh hello picked up a broken ladder okay
good thing I just stuffed it in my
pocket a giant big old ladder was that I
heard it tink like someone banging metal
you hear that right I'm not going crazy
okay come here
Oh HM ridin how finally God have you
been helped me I would be much obliged
Oh oh yeah you like the first living
person I've ever seen
in these games Oh a lever no oh ooh oh
no that lever is bad haha okay don't
test the lever don't doesn't look Rock
um uh see anything um ooh nope forgive
me no I don't think so
it's a tennis racket ha nope just Dean
my love I know that I am not as talented
as my law or as strong as Basile but
love is true even if you killed the seal
if you wish he's hurting you trick him
to consume bromide poor Justine okay
Justine I Lord forgive me no no no
forgiveness no forgiveness
okay yeah what what what
Oh
okay someone give it a prayer that's
nice
okay this yummy it's not too late to set
things right
oh it's not Oh save you it I guess oh
hey this is good it won't budge
iron it open up I got a chair yeah good
good dark dark girlfriend up that do it
okay don't want much um what the hell
carpenter I don't know are there just
different sounds in all these different
rooms I'm guessing okay huh totally not
scary bring it on
Oh got a bottle what's that piano okay
that's nice I suppose
huh what where is he crazy
hahaha get tough a boost what happened
haha hey where did he come from
No no bucket don't betray me don't
betray me bucket oh hello
hi buddy how's it going buddy oh that's
the guy oh that's the guy from abduction
oh they didn't make any Molly's bar this
odd I'm so stupid
why didn't I just play the expansion
right after your little game I don't
know
Oh nope okay salutations Victor Moreau
chief uh please turn your repose to
Justine versus the affair started alloy
that's a guy from the other note um
Mademoiselle Justine's actions mister
what does that I didn't know if that was
in actually in my rumor in the game
sorry I'm stupid I'm stupid okay yeah
cause good
you get sound like you got some trouble
breathing there buddy let's get some
inhaler or something or just get the
fudge out of here
huh okay everything okay I've been in
every room in there I think there
must've been something there was like
hallway said I didn't go down huh huh
yeah get out here
hey everybody okay here buddy buddy ha
ha ha ha ha close oh I didn't slam the
door wasn't me he wasn't me buddy was it
me wait what would you say
say something buddy can you actually
talk go away
no it likes you he doesn't look very
strong so I don't know if you'd like be
a threat or something
maybe I'm just a wimpy wimpy dude
probably am I mean if Daniel is anything
to go by him biggest wimp in the world
ok I'm guessing he was guarding
something that I needed all right what
do we got here came from today this is
where I got the broken ladder I think
I'm not sure um nothing here whoa
okay I do here like tinking on rocks or
metal or something maybe there are other
people here I mean there's one live guy
even though he's kind of wrapped up but
at least he's alive I don't know I think
I have the power to kill him but uh I'm
not gonna do that I'm not that mean
okay nothing there guess what the hacky
hack the heck something up up there
maybe I don't know I don't I'm here
buddy I'm a savior somehow okay there's
got to be something there's got to be
something that I'm missing gotta be
gotta be I don't have any oil and I have
a lantern but nothing to use it with
don't even know why they gave it to me
okay um oh hey hi there
ooh I gotta get up there okay I'm gonna
stack up there okay boxes I hate box
stacking but I'll do it I have to okay
um come get oh yeah get in there
good thing I'm good thing I know my
super box stacking skills from my time
in penumbra oh yeah that was like the
best training in the world most
aggravating training but best in the
world
Oh is gonna take forever okay Jebus get
me get me huh wait I would I didn't even
try so sergeant bust through the doors
anyway I think that's it it's like a
girl's voice or something
well then oh this this expansion was
made for like the pregame stuff for the
portal too so I think they made this
expansion to sort of play on that
because Chell is a female character they
made this one like a female voices
character as well okay anyway um I'm
actually gonna cut it here and I'm gonna
build this in the meantime to get up to
there that way you don't have to just
sit through me stacking boxes so thank
you all so much for watching
and I'll get through this no worries so
thank you for watching and I will see
you in the next part bye bye